قضت المحكمه الدستوريه في مصر بعدم
الدستوريه الماده العاشره من قانون
التظاهر التي تجيز لوزاره الداخليه منع اي
مظاهره في حال وجود ما يهدد الامن لكنها
رفضت الغاء عقوبتي الحبس والغرامه على
منظمي اي مظاهرات اذا لم يحصلوا على اذن
او اخلوا بالامن او دعوا لتعطيل
الانتاج
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه كيف يمكن تفسير هذا الحكم من
الناحيتين القانونيه
والسياسيه وما خيارات النظام المصري
ومعارضيه في التعامل مع هذا الحكم
وتداعياته على الاف المعتقلين بموجب قانون
[موسيقى]
التظاهر لم يعد مجلس النواب المصري زما
بتخفيض الغاء عقوبه الحبس او الغرامات
المقرره في قانون التظاهر بعدما اقرت
المحكمه الدستوريه بسلامات المواد الناصه
على تلك العقوبات ولم تخفي مصادر نيابيه
وحكومه مصريه ارتياحها لان المحكمه
الدستوريه لم تمس جوهر قانون التظاهر الذي
طالما طالبت منظمات دوليه بالغائه واشارت
مصادر مصريه الى ان مجلس النواب سيبدا في
دراسه مقترح تعديل الماده العاشره من
قانون التظاهر والتي كانت تجيز لوزاره
الداخليه منع او تاجي او نقل موقع اي
مظاهره مسبقا في حال وجوده دلائل على ما
يهدد السلم والامن تقرير فتحي اسماعيل
وابعاد اخرى للجدل حول قانون التظاهر في
مصر سيتعين على الاف المصريين الذين
اعتقلوا بموجب قانون التظاهر البقاء طويلا
وراء القضبان بعد قرار المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا رفض الطعن في المواد السابعه
والثامنه والتاسعه عش من القانون المثير
للجدل وهو ما يعني قانونا تحصين تلك
المواد وعدم قابليتها لاي طعون باعتبار ان
الدستوريه العليا هي اعلى درجات التقاضي
في مصر وقراراتها نافذه ونهائيه وحيث ان
المواد المحصنه تتعلق بالعقوبات الوارده
بالقانون وهي التي بمقتضاها حوكم معظم
المحبوسين وفرضت على غرامات ماليه كبيره
بات الان من المستحيل استعادتها فان قرار
المحكمه لا يبدو الا تحصينا لجوهر قانون
التظاهر برمته وربما لا يغير من ذلك كثيرا
ان قضت المحكمه العليا بعدم دستوريه
الماده العاشره من القانون ما يعني ابطال
حق وزاره الداخليه في منع التظاهر
والاجتماعات فذلك يرتبط بوقائع افتراضيه
وفي في نطاق الامكان مستقبلا بينما ترتبط
المواد التي لم يقع ابطالها بمصير الاف
السجناء واموالهم وحقوقهم علما ان ما حل
بمعظمهم ترتب على الماده العاشره نفسها
هذه التي الغتها المحكمه
الدستوريه بموجب قانون التظاهر الذي اصدره
في نوفمبر من عام
2013 الرئيس المؤقت انذاك عدلي منصور اي
بعد اربعه اشهر من الانقلاب العسكري اعتقل
الاف الناشطين من الحركات الشبابيه والثور
ومن جماعه الاخوان وغيرها وبمقتضاه ايضا
حكم المشاركون في مظاهرات ابريل الماضي
المعارضه لاتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بين مصر والسعوديه والمشاركين في مظاهرات
ما عرف بثوره الغلابه في نوفمبر الماضي
لكن هذا القانون لم يكن عائقا ابدا امام
تظاهرات مؤيده لنظام السيسي ما قد يدعم
اتهامات كثيره بانه قانون مسيس للنيل من
المعارضين اما وقد قررت اعلى هيئه قضائيه
في مصر الا تنحاز للحريات التي اكتسبها
المصريون في ثوره يناير كما قال ناشطون
حقوقيون فثم من يعتقد ان تلك الخطوه تمهد
لتصعيد جديد من النظام لا ضد معارضين
السياسيين وحسب بل ضد المجتمع المدني لا
سما وان قرارات الدستوريه العليا تاتي بعد
ايام قليله من منع ناشطين من السفر وتجميد
اموالهم بالتوازي مع مسار تشريعي لا يقل
تربصا بالحريات المدنيه والسياسيه خصوصا
مع فرض البرلمان قيودا صارمه على العمل
الاهلي خلافا لما وقعت عليه مصر من اتفا
فاقات
دوليه موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيفين
من جنيف احمد مفرح المحامي والباحث
الحقوقي ومن واشنطن محمود ابراهيم المحامي
ونائب رئيس مركز الاتحاديه للدراسات سيد
محمود ابراهيم في ظل هذا الجدل بعد هذا
القرار من المحكمه الدستوريه فيما يتعلق
بقانون التظاهر بصفه عامه ما رسمته وما
يتعلق بالماده العاشره يبدو السؤال ملحا
ما الذي اضافه قرار المحكمه الدستوريه
فيما يتعلق بقانون التظاهر وما ترتب عنه
من ردود فعل داخليه
ودوليه اعتقد انه قرار المحكمه الدستوريه
بيضيف شرعيه قانونيه ودستوريه لهذا
القانون حجه المعارضين للقانون انه اصدروا
رئيس الجمهوريه في غيبه البرلمان وانه هذا
القانون غير دستوري فاقر البرلمان وتقره
المحكمه الدستوريه اذا هو قانون دستوري
اذا هو ساري اذا لا احد يجب ان يعترض عليه
ربما نريد تغييره او يريد البعض تغييره
يتجه الى البرلمان الجهه التشريعيه
التي منوض بها تغيير هذا القانون غير ذلك
كلنا ملتزمون بهذا القانون انت تعلم بان
وجه الاعتراض الاساسي على هذا القانون
عشرات الالاف من المسجونين والمتابعين
والملاحق ان هناك جانب انساني وقانوني
وسياسي وليس فقط فيما يتعلق بدستور القرار
من قبل
والان
يعني انا الحقيقه مستغرب جدا جدا جدا جدا
يعني الناس تخالف القانون فنقول
عليهم يعني اولا انا اعترض كمان على لفظ
معتقلين هم محبوسين ومدان في قضايا مخالفه
قانون مخالفه القانون بهما كان العدد كبير
لا تعفي انه قانون في حراميه كتير في
السجن مش معناه انهم يعني القانون وحش لكن
معناه انهم خالفوا القانون مخالفه القانون
دي مساله يجب ان نقف عليها لن ينسى
المصريون منا ناظر حرق محمد محمود مناظر
حرق المجمع العلمي المظاهرات الغير منضبطه
حرق سيارات الشرطه حرق اموال ونهب اموال
المواطنين خلال المظاهرات هذه مسائل لا
ينسها المصريين واضت الاموال الخاصه واضت
المصريين في في قوتهم و جدا جدا جدا من ج
احمد مفرح لاساله عن هذه المساله الان
اصبحت الامور دستوريه والقانون اصبح
دستوريا وبالتالي يرى فيه ضيفي ويرى فيه
اخرون حتى حقوقيون من داخل مصر بانه خطووه
الى الامان فيما يتعلق بتطبيق العداله في
مصر هل تراها
كذلك ا في البدايه برحب بحضرتك وبرحب
الساده المشاهدين ا وانا ايضا استغرب جدا
جدا جدا يعني فيما يخص ان يتم قبول قانون
قمعي ليس له اي نوع من انواع يعني
القانونيه لو تحدثنا حولين واذا كان كان
حتى ما بعد حتى المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
وحكمها ف فال المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
وحكمها ليس سق غفران حتى نستطيع ان نقبل
بمثل هذا القانون القمعي دون مواد القمعيه
الذي ليس له اي علاقه بالمعايير الدوليه
على سبيل المثال وبالتالي ف فالامر يعني
محسوم بالنسبه الينا نحنا كحقوق ومتابعين
للشان المصري نعمل وفق المعايير الدوليه
التي على اساسها مصر بتتعامل مع القوانين
وبتتعامل مع التشريعات وايضا مع الشارعه
الدوليه ان هذا القانون ايا ما كان وضعه
سواء كان قر او قر تم اقراره من المجلس او
مجلس النواب او تم اقراره من المحكمه
الدستوريه سيظل قانون قمعي سيظل من تم
القاء القبض عليهم بسبب هذا القانون
معتقلين تعسفا بسبب انهم معتقلين بسبب
حريه راي
وتعبير تعد خطوه الماده العاشره خطوه
ايجابيه في تحويلها من وزاره
الداخليه سيد احمد
لا لا لا لا لا اتخيل هذا الامر الامر
بالنسبه لينا ليس مواده وانما هو فلسفه
قانون فلسفه قانون هذا القانون هو هو
بالاساس عباره عن حضانه يعني لن يستطيع
النظام في مصر ان يخرج من خلالها الا الا
او ان يستمر في الحكم الا بسبب هذا
القانون وبالتالي فهو لا يقضي فقط على
الحق في التظاهر وهو حق اصيل دستوريا وحق
اصيل قانونيا وفقا للمعايير والمواثيق
والمعادلات الدوليه وانما يقضي ايضا على
المجتمع ذاته حينما نتحدث عن ان الحق في
التظاهر اصبح حقا يعني للاسف الشديد ق من
القمعيه بمكان ان يتم التعامل معه بالحبس
ان يتم التعامل معه بالرفض ان يتم التعامل
معه بالقاء القبض على المعتقلين حتى وان
توهمهم وان وان يعني فكروا ان يقوموا
بالتظاهر فهذا امر مخل حتى لمعايير
العداله لا نستطيع ان نقبله باي حال من
الاحوال وبالتالي فانا اقول في يتعلق
بمعاير الاله من واشنطن محمود ابرايم هذا
القانون سيد محمود كان مثار انتقاد من
جهات دوليه وخارجيه ومنظمات حتى خارجيه
خارج مصر ووصفته بانه قانون قمعي يعني حتى
ارجع الامور الى اسوا ما كانت عليه قبل
الثوره المصريه قبل الثوره الخم من يناير
اشرت الى انه اصبح الان دستوريا هل دستر
القمع مطمئنه بالنسبه لك وتجعل هذا
القانون يعني مساله طبيعيه
الان
اسمح لي ارد بنقطتين النقطه الاولى ويعني
ارجو انها ما تبانش انها مبالغه لكن هي في
الواقع انه نقارن مثلا بين قانون تنظيم
التظاهر في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وقانون تنظيم التظاهر في مصر ومقارنه جاده
بدون اي انحيازات ونشوف ايه الفرق بين ده
وبين ده دي مساله المساله الثانيه انه
تنظيم الحق لا يعني منع الحق انا سامع
كلمات من نوعيه قمع ومش عارف الغاء وبتاع
تنظيم الحق عمره ما كان من ابدا هذا قانون
لتنظيم الحق في التظاهر ولم ي الان تكرر
سيد محمود فقط ملاحظه ثم ثم اعطيك لتكمل
انت الان تكرر ما قاله عدلي منصور الرئيس
المؤقت حينما كان حينما كان حينها واصدر
هذا القانون قانون التظاهر وقال بان
قوانين التظاهر في مصر هي حتى افضل من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تفضل انا مش عاييز اقول افضل انا عايز
اقول ان احنا خلينا نجري مقارنه موضوعيه
بعيدا عن اي انحيازات سياسيه يعني نجيب
اثنين من الدنمارك يقعدوا يقارنوا
القانونين ويقولوا ايه الفرق بين ده وبين
ده انما في الحقيقه انا مره ثانيه تنظيم
الحق غير قامع الحق غير منع الحق غير
المنع المنع في ممارسته نحن نتحدث عن
قانون ينظم الحق في التظاهر المواطنين
المصريين من حقهم يتظاهروا ولكن وفقا
للقانون وفقا للقواعد التي وضعها القانون
ليه لانه ده بي المواطين المصريين
سيدم هل المواطنين المصريين سواء فيما
يتعلق بهذا القانون عندما يخرج من
يتظاهرون لصالح النظام يسمح لهم عندما
يخرج اخرون يع اعترضوا حتى على قرات من
قبل النظام وقد كانوا جزءا منه يدخلون
السجن بدون محاكمه والى الان تجري
محاكمتهم واوراق في العداله اذا عن اي
قانون واي مقارنه بين مصر وبين اي دوله
سواء امريكا او الدنمارك او غير ذلك ما
ذكرت قبل
قليل يعني هنا ممكن بقى ان ناخد المساله
من مساله نصوص القانون الى مساله تطبيق
القانون والوقائع فكل وقائعه بوقائع
بذاتها يعني اه ربما يكون يعني منطقي بديه
انه السلطه حينما تجد مؤيدين لها يقفون في
الشارع بيهتف لها وبيدو ورد وبيقولوا شكرا
للشرطه او للجيش غير لما بيبقى واحد واقف
بيشتم وبيقول يسقط حكم العسكر او غيره
يعني دي مسائل منطقيه في الب يعني بديهيه
في التعامل مع المسائل اليوميه القانون
هنا ده بعيدا عن نص القانون ده تطبيق
القانون دي دي مسائل يعني تبدو منطقيه جدا
لكن مره ثانيه انا عايز ااكد انه الحقوق
والحريات هي في الاصل حقوق وحريات
المواطنين الذين يتضررون من التظاهر الغير
منظم هو ده الهم هذهه الخطوه اسال ضيفي من
جنيب احمد مفرح ما الذي دفع الحكومه
المصريه او الدوله المصريه او الى هذه
الخطوه فيما يتعلق بقرار المحكمه
الدستوريه وقد كان القرار ساريا وتم على
اثره الاجراء الكثير من الاعتقالات وتم
تنفيذه ما الذي دفع الدوله المصريه الى
اتخاذ هذه الخطوه الان
برايك
يعني هو انا بس عايز اوضح نقطه في غايه
الاهميه انا لا اريد ان ادخل في المصطلحات
ما اجمل نحنا عندنا في مصر للاسف التشريع
في مصر من بعد 30 يونيو وهو يتميز
بالمصطلحات يعني البراقه واذا دخلت في
اعماق القوانين في التشريع انا اتحدث عن
التشريع واذا دخلت في اعماق القوانين تجد
يعني المصطلحات الفضفاضه التي ليس لها
معنى وليس لها واقع من قانون وبالتالي
فلعب على موضوع المصطلحات تنظيم ام اغلاق
او خلافه ليس له اي علاقه بالواقع القمع
الذي يعيشه المجتمع المصري بسبب هذا
القانون لا ليس له اي علاقه ب 37000 ووقع
اعتقال تمت منذ اقرار هذا القانون في شهر
11/23 لغيه الان وبالتالي في هذه النقطه
يجب ان يتم حسمها ويجب ان يتم توضيحها
بشكل بشكل عادل مناط العداله حينما نتحدث
عن العداله فنحن في في قانون التظاهر ليس
فقط نتحدث عن ان هناك اشخاص يعني يقوموا ب
بالتظاهر بسبب معارضتهم للدوله او للنظام
واشخاص يقوموا بتظاهر بسبب فرحهم لقرارات
الدوله في الحالتين في في عداله يجب ان
تقوم الدوله بتطبيق العداله وحينما لا
تقوم الدوله بتطبيق معايير العداله فانه
لن توجد هناك اي نوع من انواع المصداقيه
لدى المجتمع في ان يعترف بمثل هذه الدوله
او يعترف حتى بقوانينها على سبيل المثال ا
فيما يخص سؤال حضرتك ف فالامر في غايه
الاهميه دعني اوضح نقطه مهمه الحكومه
المصريه الان بعد ان تمت اقرار قانون بعد
ثلاث سنوات من اقرار هذا القانون القمعي
سوف من المفترض على من المفترض انها ستقوم
بتعديل الماده العاشره لكن هذا التعديل لن
ياتي او لن يثمر باي حال من الاحوال على
الوضع الراهن ااء النتائج التي ترتب عليها
تطبيق هذا القانون انا اتحدث على سبيل
المثال هنا في جنيف من المفترض انه يعني
في السنه القادمه ستقوم مصر
بتقديم الاستفسارات والرد على الاساله
الخاصه باستعاره الدوري الشامل واهمها ه
هذا القانون هذا القانون
قانون ال خيارات النظام وكذلك معارضين في
التعامل مع هذا الحكم وهذا القرار من قبل
المحكمه الدستوريه سيد محمود ابراهيم فيما
يتعلق بما ذكره ضيفي قبل قليل العشرات من
الالاف من الذين اعتقلوا بهذا القرار خاصه
الماده العاشره ماذا عن مصيرهم الان بعدما
اصبح القرار يقتضي بان العوده الى القضاء
ليس الى وزاره الداخليه في مساله
التظاهر اولا انا لا اعلم العدد حضرتك
جبته منين سنيا هم ليسوا معتقلين هم وهذا
ليس قرار هذا قانون هؤلاء محبوسين وفقا
لقانون وبالتالي ليسوا معتقلين وفقا
للقرار دي قانونيه لازم تبقى واضحه جدا
محمود انا ما عنديش رقم لكن من حقي ان انا
اشكك في اي رقم حد بيقول بالبق على عشرات
الالاف الرقم ربما قد يتج
35 لا هم هم ممكن يطلعوا 100 في الاخر
يعني اللي محبوسين وفقا لانه حضرتك في
واحد بيتقبض عليه م ملتوف ومعمول له جنايه
وبعدين تقول عليه كان ماشي في الشارع
بيتظاهر يعني دي مسائل بقى نقعد نتكلم
فيها يعني لكن اصلا المحبوسين في مصر كلهم
ما يوصلو للارقام دي حتى المحبوسين في
قضايا تحسبها انت س او يحسبها البعض
سياسيا يعني ف ف دعنا بس
نروح لنص القانون نفسه القانون نظم الحريه
الافراد في عشان الاستاذ احمد بيتكلم عن
العداله انا لا افهم الحقيقه برده مساله
ان العداله المصريه وفقا للقواعد والشرع
الدوليه لحقوق الانسان ا في في مصر مرت
بظروف سياسيه ست اعوام او او خمسه اعوام
من الفوضى ده خلق ظرف سياسي ادى الى ان
المواطنين القانون في الاخر هو تعبير عن
رغبه المواطنين في تنظيم امورهم ف هنا
مساله العداله دي مساله مختلفه شويه لكن
القانون في الاساس المجتمعات بت بتسن
القوانين لتنظيم حياتهم وتنظيم امورهم
فالمجتمع المصري توافق في هذه اللحظه على
انه التظاهر به في الجزء الثاني واعتذر
منك سييد محمود في الجزء من هذه الحلقه
سوف نناقش مساله كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
الخيارات المطروحه امام النظام المصري
ومعارضيه في التعامل مع هذا الحكم
وتداعياته على الاف المعتقلين بموجب قانون
التظاهر ابقوا معنا
رجاء
[موسيقى]
ا
اهلا بكم مجددا في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش
مصير قانون التظاهر في مصر والمعتقلين
بموجبه بعد ابطال المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا حق وزاره الداخليه في منع التظاهر
من مع ابقاء مواد العقوبات في هذا القانون
سيد احمد مفرح الان السؤال عن الخيارات
امام معارضي هذا القانون بعدما كان قانونا
بقرار الان اخذ الصبغه الدستوريه ما
الخيارات مع هذا القانون المثير للجدل
نعم يعني هناك نقطه في رايه الاهميه اححب
ان اوضحها قانون التظاهر لم ياتي رغبه من
من المواطنين المصريين يعني هذا كلام
مخالف تماما للواقع الذي يعيش فيه الشارع
المصري قانون التظاهر تم اقراره من قبل
الرئيس المؤقت عدلي منصور بعد ان تم
اعطاءه صلاحيات التشريع بعد الانقلاب
العسكري في 3ه يوليو وبالتالي فهو اقره ثم
تم بعد ذلك اقراره من مجلس النواب وللاسف
الشديد السبب في الطعن امام الدستور
العليا هو عدم رغبه المجتمع المصري
والمظلومين بسبب هذا القانون وبالتالي
لجؤوا الى القضاء المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا وللاسف لم تنصفهم ايضا المحكمه
الدستور العليا وبالتالي فعلى اي رغبه
يعني يعني انا لا ايضا اذا كنا نشكك في
الارقام فنحن ايضا نشكك في المصطلحات التي
يتم التعامل مع في في فيما تم فيما تم في
في هذه الحلقه الخيارات التي الامر بشكل
واضح في البدايه تم رفض هذا القانون ليس
فقط لا بسبب الماده العاشره وانما تم رفض
القانون كلي بسبب ما فيه من مواد قمعيه ما
فيه من سلطه يعني استبداد تؤثر وتؤدي الى
يعني انهاء الحق في التظاهر ما فيه وما تم
بسببه من القاء القبض على المعتقلين وانا
كل معتقلين لانه طبقا للمعايير الدوليه
يعني طبقا
ل الفريق العام للمعني بالاعتقال التعسفي
من تم ما تم اعتقاله من المظاهره فهو
معتقل فهو معتقل تعسفيا هذا الامر واه الم
وا بسبب مث بسبب هذ الزج س محمود ابراهيم
وعضل المقاطعه سيد احمد الزج بالمحكمه
الدستوريه في قضيه كهذه في قانون هو مثار
للجدل ولرفض من قبل شرائح مختلفه في داخل
مصر وفي خارج مصر اليس معناه الزج بهيئه
لها مكانتها في خلاف سياسي وفي في مخاض
سياسي قد يورط هذه المحكمه في المستقبل
وفي
مصداقيتها اسمح لي بس برده تعقيب سريع على
الاستاذ احمد انه ا يعني انا لما اشكك رق
لما حضرتك
تشكك معلش بس معلش بس برلمان منتخب ورئيس
جمهوريه ومحكمه اعلى محكمه في مصر دول
مؤسسات يجب ان نحترمها البرلمان المنتخب
ده لما يقر القانون احنا نحترمه لكن انا
لما اشكك في رقم انا راجل قاعد في واشنطن
اشكك في رقم ولكنه موصوف من قبل فريق
سياسي بانه نظام انقلابي
ايضا يعني دي دي دي ده رايي لكن قانون تم
اقراره القوانين لتنظيم المجتمعات ده اقره
البرلمان واقره الرئيس واقره المحكمه
الدستوريه حضرتك بقى بتتكلم عن المحكمه
الدستوريه والزج ا مره ثانيه المحكمه
الدستوريه هنا لا تحمي الحريات وتحمي
المواطنين كي يكونوا مطمئنين انه البرلمان
ده ما
بيشرشح قرارات تخالف او تاتي على حريتهم
المحكمه الدستوريه هي يلجا اليها
المواطنين لكي يحمي حريتهم بالعكس قد يكون
القانون غير دستوري او او غير مطابق
للمعايير اذا تم اعتماده ولم يتم مراجعه
احد هذا الفصل ومراقبه السلطات لبعضها
البعض هو مناطق الحريات والديمقراطيات وهو
اللي بيحمي حاله المجتمع اما السياسه هي
التي تدخل السياسه بقى هي اللي بتدخل
الكلام الثاني في الكلام ده ادرك الوقت
كنت معنا من واشنطن محمود ابراهيم المحامي
ونائب رئيس مركز الاتحاديه للدراسات شكرا
جزيلا لك ما اشكر ضيفي من جنيف احمد مفرح
المحابي والباحث الحقوقي شكرا جزيلا لكما
الى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله